we have a voicemail number 219 to david  p I don't think I really need to  introduce this voicemail it's pretty  self-explanatory take a listen I saw you  on TV you look like Ellen DeGeneres I've  not heard that before I have not heard  that before I've heard other people I  don't think I need to name them but I  have not heard that one before on the  bonus show today we will talk new  england patriots i do want to talk about  some of the more political super bowl  commercials and i also had a very  hostile running with someone in person  over the weekend and i'll tell you that  story make sure you get the bonus show  david pakman.com slash membership coupon  code i voted 17 is still available for  you